investigators looking into the alleged
hate crime against Empire actor Jesse
Smollett are examining a threatening
letter sent last month now a source told
our CBS Chicago station WBBM quote when
the letter didn't get enough attention
Smollett concocted the staged attack
Dean Reynolds his outside Chicago Police
Headquarters Dean good morning good
morning Chicago Police have stopped
calling Smollett the victim in this case
and are referring to him now merely as
the individual who reported the incident
and CBS News has learned two brothers
admitted to the police that the actor
paid them to fake that incident when
police raided the home of brothers Ola
and Abel O son died row last week one of
the items seized was a magazine that's
notable because the week before jussie
Smollett says he was beaten by two
masked race-baiting homophobes who
yelled this is Magga country standings
the Empire star received a threatening
letter at the Chicago studios where his
show is filmed the words appeared to be
spelled out with letters clipped from a
magazine CBS news legal analyst Ricky
Clemens so the question I ask as a
prosecutor is what was the motive of the
brothers to do any of this why would
they do this multiple sources tell CBS
Chicago station WBBM Smollett was upset
the letter didn't get a bigger reaction
and decided to orchestrate the attack
CBS News has learned the US and IRA
brothers have now admitted to police
Smollett hired them to stage the assault
investigators have requested a follow-up
interview with Smollett who has
repeatedly denied faking the attack I'm
pissed off how do you not believe that
it's the truth
SMO lets lawyers say he knows the
brothers one of whom was his personal
trainer in a video posted on Facebook
last month a Veloz and Iroh a
bodybuilder practiced posing to one of
smollett song
Oh Lowe's and Iroh appeared in the
second season of Empire the men told
WBBM we are not racist
we are not homophobic and we are not
anti-trump we were born and raised in
Chicago and our American citizens here
you have he said they said so I'm sure
the Chicago Police are looking for any
type of corroborating evidence for days
the police here have very publicly
requested another interview with
smollett because of all the information
they've gathered recently much of that
information undermining the actors
version of what he says happened to him
three weeks ago today Norah
all right Dean Reynolds your reporting
has been spot on since day one on this
story so thanks to you we appreciate a
lot of people jump to conclusions when
you first heard it it's always a
reminder to wait till you hear the whole
part of the story right we're always
reminds us as that that Dean thank you
again